let's bring in iowa congresswoman ashley
hinson who is pushing a bill to defund
president biden's secret migrant flights
good morning to you
good morning carly tell us about this
bill absolutely
yeah well president biden through his
policies has brought this border crisis
directly to iowans and americans
backyards and so i introduced the stop
the betrayal act you talk about those
hundreds of millions of dollars of
taxpayer money that is funding these
flights bringing illegal immigrants into
our country how bizarre that we even
have to have this conversation but
unfortunately it's necessary with what
this administration is doing so the stop
the betrayal act would stop the funding
to bring those flights into our country
those middle of the night dead of the
night bus drops that we're seeing
happening as well because the american
people deserve transparency on this
issue and they've been betrayed by
president biden and his deliberate
efforts to mislead the american people
yeah without a doubt and from one crisis
to another nypd police officer wilbur
mora's sister she delivered a powerful
eulogy at his funeral yesterday take a
listen to her message
to our our leaders listen here
juantos wilbur
how many wilberts how many jasons
how many more officers have to lose
their lives before this system changes
the nypd protects us but who protects
them and who looks after their lives
and i think that's a question that is on
the minds of many americans
how many more officers how many more
people need to lose their lives before
the system changes congresswoman
yeah my heart goes out to officer maura
and his family i mean what an absolute
tragedy that this
to happen our law enforcement officers
men and women they get up every day they
put on that badge they put on that
uniform they go out and protect our
communities and
it's no surprise that we're at this
place in our country right now where the
soft on crime rhetoric and the soft on
crime policies have intersected and we
are seeing that increased crime in our
community um and so again i think this
is a place where we have to have our law
enforcement officers backs i know we do
in iowa and we need to make sure we're
doing that across the country yeah and
you know congressman really it boils
down to an ideology here that
america is a racist evil place so the
criminals are really the victims and
it's really hard to root out an ideology
do you think that things will ever
really change with that in place
yeah well i think the american people
have had enough of this whether it's
what's happening at the border or what's
happening with law enforcement in our
communities americans want to feel safe
and secure if we don't have safety and
security what do we have so again we
should be spending 300 million dollars
instead of bringing illegal immigrants
into our country we should be
our customs and border patrol agents
putting their lives on the line at the
border we should be making sure our law
enforcement officers have the tools that
they need to keep our communities safe
and most importantly we need to make
sure that we as citizens are standing up
and saying to the people who are
continuing to push these destructive
soft on crime policies we've had enough
and we're not going to tolerate that in
our communities we have our law
enforcement officers backs all right
without a doubt congresswoman ashley
henson thank you so much for joining us
this morning
thanks carly you bet hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now